baby to give up everything for one
person love is a powerful thing Oh
season 2 of 90-day fiance the other way
is here people I'm 26 years old and I'm
from Palm Beach Florida and Brittany she
is my mood right now if I had my hair
down of course it would be swinging I
would be flipping my hair because I am
so ready to dig into these new couples
and to catch up on some familiar ones
this season we are headed to Ethiopia
Mexico Jordan India South Korea and
Colombia hi my 90 day fans film its
Malizia here how did you feel about the
premiere personally I enjoyed it for a
few reasons
let's go ahead and get into the
highlights first up Britney is keeping a
huge secret from her Jordanian fiance
yaz I'm I really want to get married to
my fiance but I'm so married to my art
oh I didn't expect that did you expect
that that came out of left field for me
I didn't expect Britney to still be
married but it is 90 day fiancé
we always get the unexpected right let's
dig back into what she revealed in the
episode when it comes to her marriage
she said that she married her ex five
years ago about three or four months
after they got married he got deported
by ice literally right after we married
he got deported and it was actually I
counted it as a blessing and totally
forgot about him our relationship was
not good he was very very controlling
through all of that she still managed to
forget that she was married which is
really interesting but to make matters
worse Ghassan has no clue that she still
is married and his family wants them to
get married as soon as she gets to
Jordan I think this is a lesson for all
of us finish what you start before you
get into something else especially if
it's a marriage thanks for that lesson
Brittany the attorney made a really good
point she told Brittany that is best to
talk to guys on about it now before she
actually goes to Jordan she said that
she understands how you don't want to
have this conversation face-to-face but
it's a whole nother story when you're
having a conversation face-to-face about
being married still to your fiance and
you're in another country right you're
by yourself in another country
Brittany's dad is already worried about
her he had to smile through the whole
conversation that's how worried he is I
will say this I like Brittany I think
she's gonna be a fan favorite
I think she might even be a breakout
star she does her own thing and she
likes to have a good time
you heard her admit that she dated an 85
year old and she didn't care what any of
us thought about it okay
probably about 83 or 84 she said yes I
did I only date men 45 and older and to
liaison came in the picture and she
actually revealed that she dated someone
85 years old yeah so I have one question
for Brittany and I can't wait to see how
this is gonna play out and the rest of
the show are you going to continue your
rap career in Jordan I need access to
them accounts so assessing me that's my
question
next up Ariela opens up about her fears
of giving birth in Ethiopia did you have
plans to return here so as of right now
the plan is I'm moving to Ethiopia for
us to live there indefinitely yeah Wow I
think it's really important for both
parents to be present at the birth so
the only way we can do that is by me
moving teeth you okay but I'm nervous
about it because obviously
they speak a different language it's a
different culture and they have
different you know facilities you know
no they're not being an epidural like
that's something that really scares me
the women in that class tried so hard
not to show what they were thinking on
their faces they didn't want to judge
her
they gave her enough space to express
her plans and she did just that
she says she's making this sacrifice so
Binyam can be there for the birth of his
son you can't argue with that
but I mean the reality of it is is that
this is a huge risk and this is a
life-or-death risk a lot of people would
only dream to come to the states to have
their baby because of the care you can
get here in American hospitals
I spoke with Ariela last month here's
what she teased about her delivery
experience I think that that is gonna be
one of the most emotional and you know
amazing scenes for everyone to sort of
experience and I really feel like it
will it's just it's such a great part of
the story I really think people will
feel very connected to me into our whole
story once they see that scene speaking
to Ariella really gave me the
opportunity to get to know her a little
bit better and I just got the gist that
she's just a free spirit she's just a
woman who walks to the beat of her own
drum a brave woman who walks to the beat
of her own drum but she just does her
own thing
and you can't really be mad at that she
also opened up to me about her
relationship with Binyam she stressed
that it is genuine and the connection is
real no matter what anybody might say or
think
finally our mando opens up about his
former wife and the first time he tried
to come out to his family after we had
been married for about eight years I
decided to tell Hannah's mother that I
was gay
when I first told her she was kind of
lost and she definitely cried about it
the day after I told her she actually
called my mom into the room and and she
told her my mom just started bawling and
she would say I don't know my son isn't
gay you can't be you know you're married
my heart breaks for Armando I feel like
every human being deserves to feel the
freedom that comes with being
authentically yourself right you deserve
to feel that freedom especially around
the people that you love Kenneth and
Armando they're 26 years apart they are
the franchise's first mill gay couple I
actually had the chance to speak with
them earlier this month and I acts
Armando what made you say yes to doing
the show knowing that your family
doesn't approve of your sexuality here's
what he had to say obviously I was
afraid to come out or the world to know
that I'm gay because I you know I was
just afraid all around but in a way it
was like it was something to kind of
push me um push myself when you go
through the hardest moment in the end
it's like you end up having like a great
outcome so I was just hoping for that we
rip the band-aid off yes real quick I'll
go ahead and say it I love them I think
that relationship is so genuine I think
their love is so real and I can see how
they benefit one another
Kenneth's being 26 years older then
Armando actually serves our mando really
well Kenneth is a man who came out to
his family who has been walking around
feeling free as a gay man in this world
for some time now and that's something
that are my
nice guidance on so I see how they
benefit one another and I am rooting for
them for sure during our conversation I
asked Armando
how has Kenneth changed your life for
the better how has he helped you here's
what he has to say I've learned a lot
I've grown a lot I learned to love
myself to accept myself to know almost
like right from wrong to learn from my
mistakes and all around just I think has
made me a better person and also not
feel like I'm a victim in any way or not
feel like I'm less but to grow and to be
above everything based off of our sneak
peak we have a lot more in store for the
rest of the season
[Music]
bring those summit is ignoring the
haters and moving forward with Jenny
Jenny clips are pretty good movement no
order escape we did with me mama should
be a mother
Ariela is actually going to go through
with having the baby in Ethiopia I'm
sailing stressed about Ariela staying
here to have our baby when things go
wrong they go wrong come
and Brittany is not really meshing well
with the advanced culture so my family
you don't - I don't understand what's
going on like I don't get it
make sure you stick with ET because we
are going to cover it all right here see
you next time
[Music]